Okay, so we'll just do intros from our side real quick because there's fewer of us than
there are of you guys.
So I'll kick it off.
My name is Daniel Aston.
I'm the SVP of engineering here at Dask Technology, been here for a little over six years.
We work in automotive and the automotive space and many different SaaS solutions for that.
I've been in engineering for, you know, 13, 14, 15 years now, started off coding and now
kind of more of the management side of things.
Excited to kick it off.
To my counterpart here to my right is Alex, if you want to go ahead and introduce yourself.
Yeah.
How's it going, guys?
Alex English, SVP of product here at Dask Technology, Dan and I work very closely together
on a daily basis.
I've been with the company for 15 years now, 14 years, 14 years last month.
My background is operational.
I was a leader on our account management team and then I was a leader on our support
team, specifically leading the team that handled all of our onboarding, deactivations and client
support.
So that gave me a strong foundation to very thoroughly understand our product mix and,
you know, the value props and how we talk to clients and the ebbs and flows of, you
know, what causes retention.
And so it was a natural fit for me to move into product.
I've been leading the product team for about four years now.
So happy to be here.
Looking forward to this call and thank you very much.
Mike, you want to jump in?
Yeah.
Hey, guys.
Mike Paylor.
I'm a technology and product consultant working with Dask for the last three years.
And I've known and worked with the Dask team for probably 13 years now, off and on.
I've been working for instance at PayPal and Upwork as VP of engineering and CTO roles
at some small startups, things of that nature.
So I've been working with these guys on infrastructure, DevOps, cost savings, you know, product implementations.
And I'm excited because we've been thinking about this CDP for a long time.
And Dan and I and Alex, we've talked about it off and on, and we're excited to get started.
And I think you'll see from, you know, Alex, the sort of wide breadth of the product and
the space that Dask plays in and the importance of this CDP will become pretty apparent.
So nice to meet you guys.
And I'll pass it over to you, Leo.
Right.
I'm going to keep mine short in the interest of time and everybody knows me.
So I'm Leo.
I'm the leader of this here group of young whippersnappers, essentially been in tech
for 20 something years and done a little bit of everything, ops, data, coding, and now
AI and AI infrastructure and cloud and all that stuff.
I'll be, you know, joining in and playing and wearing multiple hats and also playing,
you know, central coordinator.
If you have any needs, please come to me.
And that goes for, you know, basically everybody on this call.
So I'll pass it off to Luis and then you guys can popcorn over to each other from there.
Okay.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Luis Hernandez.
I am an engineer.
I have been working on this for 30 years.
I did a lot of things in distributed systems.
I have been working with conflict for six years.
So we have a lot of different projects every year.
So that is nice.
Yeah.
I'm happy to be here and help to build this.
Alicia.
Hi.
My name is Alicia.
I'm the data engineer here.
I've been working with data for too long now, for over 20 years.
And been working with conflict for some years now.
So happy to be here.
Glad to be of help.
And hopefully we can pull this project out.
Really, really nice.
And I see Oscar over here.
Okay.
Well, my name is Oscar.
I have, like, more than 13 years of experience working with software, doing some development.
Like the new here in conflict, I have, like, a year and a half, maybe, working with Leo
directly.
Yeah.
So, yes, I've been working in different kind of applications from microservices, API, JSONs,
queues and all this kind of stuff.
So, yes.
It's a pleasure to know you, and it will be a pleasure to work with you.
And I see Byron.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Byron.
I am one of the software engineers that is going to be working on the project.
I've been working with Leo for about three years, I think, a little bit more, maybe.
And in total for around eight years.
It's a pleasure to meet you and to get us started.
Hiram.
Cool.
Hey.
Really nice to meet you.
My name is Hiram, or Hiram, or it's really widely pronounced, so however you feel the
most comfortable pronouncing my name, it's okay.
I am one of the software engineers that I've been working here since 2023, I believe.
And prior to that, I had a beautiful experience on e-commerce, a little bit of cybersecurity.
And right now I'm focusing on full stack engineering.
I've been really enjoying it, and, yeah, I'm really excited to work with you guys and get
to know you better.
Julio.
Hey.
So, yeah.
I'm Julio.
I have, like, eight years of experience and almost four with Conflict.
I am a full stack engineer.
I have been in projects of all categories and types, from DevOps to UI, so, yeah, I'm
ready to do everything.
Awesome.
Very nice to meet everybody.
And I think we have Craig.
So, if you want to chime in.
Yes.
Hey, everybody.
So sorry I'm late.
Good old-fashioned Teams update.
Anyways, Dan, let's see, Dan and Mike, we'll have a quiz later on all the representatives
of Conflict.
But thrilled to kick this off, and I hope everybody's doing well.
Craig Irwin, responsible for all things commercially related.
Thanks, Craig.
And nice to meet everybody.
Sorry we didn't get to interject each time you went, but good to get everybody's background
and appreciate you all joining.
So, Leo, do you want to take it from here?
Sure.
So, basically, I wanted to align on, like, purpose, objective, and duration.
You know, we've got about 50 more minutes left in the hour.
I unfortunately have a hard stop, because I've got another meeting right after this.
But we can schedule, like, more time subsequent if we need to dive in deeper.
I kind of put in some rough notes on, you know, basically, you know, some time to overview
and a little bit of discussion and some guiding questions to kind of take us along.
This isn't, you know, a formal guide.
It's more like conversation starters to kind of really get a sense for the initial.
And then we'll cover some basics like, you know, data sharing and access and some of
that stuff, which we'll need to be able to do, like, the rest of the discovery.
So with that in mind, I guess I'll kick us off on basically, you know, scope alignment
and, you know, hear from you for a little bit on basically, you know, your goals, what
we're, you know, building here together, and, you know, what it takes for us to kind of
knock it out of the park.
Cool.
Do you want, maybe just to ground everybody on what we're trying to build.
I don't know if everybody on the conflicts has been brought up to speed on, you know,
what it is we're trying to go after, Leo.
But perhaps, I don't know, Dan or I could sort of summarize, you know, what we're trying
to build here and the why.
And that might help sort of understand what the scope is or needs to be.
Right.
Just for a little context, I've shared the proposal and some of the documentation, but
it's always good to still get the kind of intro to make sure that everybody kind of
shares common language and all that stuff.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we can just tag team it, Dan.
But basically, I'll try to keep it fast.
So, GIS has a pretty broad portfolio of applications, and the use cases span from, like, media and
advertisement services for car dealerships to, you know, lead response when someone is
interested in a vehicle to reputation management and reputation services, helping car dealerships
maintain their reputation.
And so, the thought here is that throughout the last 15 years of the existence of the
company, we've developed these silos of sources of record outside of the fact that, of course,
we have a data lake and a reporting engine and all these things.
But we're looking to build first class experiences for consumers that tie all of their different
touch points across, like, email and web and, you know, lead response, all the different
sort of things that a consumer would do with a car dealership and sort of tie those all
together into a singular consumer data platform, so to speak.
And there are CDPs that exist out there off the shelf.
A Twilio segment comes to mind, or I don't know what the other ones are, but basic thought
is that we need to create a more unified view.
of the consumer, the consumer in this case is the person that would be working with a car
dealership to buy a car, for example. Now there's other use cases at DAS besides this one, but let's
just focus on this one for now. But how do we sort of tie the different elements of a consumer
into a CDP, which can power more interesting use cases than we can today? So for example,
we can trigger life cycle events when a consumer is showing interest in a car or visited a micro
site to sort of learn about a particular vehicle or things like that. But things we want to do like
an LLM based chat engine, LLM based like voice, these are things that are pretty industry standard
now that we do not have yet. And to make those types of experiences great, we think we need
more rich access to data about this consumer that's more co-located and available to an LLM,
if it's going to have to make reasonable texts or chats with these people.
We also want to be smarter about life cycle events. And Alex has a lot of ideas there on
how we can get better at what we do really well already, but just being smarter about
touch points with consumers on behalf of car dealerships. And so the idea of this CDP came
up several years ago, but quite frankly, the infrastructure at DAS was not ready to sort of
invest the type of time and energy and money into developing a CDP before we sort of really
overhauled some of our applications. And we've taken steps in the last two years to
overhaul a few of our applications, move them into a new tenant with a Kubernetes setup,
it's a modern sort of DevOps paradigm, but the data is still siloed.
Again, we can access the data anytime we want, anywhere, but you guys know it's really about
generating a singular consumer context and an identity graph about this consumer.
The systems today have unique capabilities, like potentially bringing consumer data
and then sending out an email on behalf of the car dealership. But what it doesn't do today,
for example, very well, if at all, is identity resolution. So if one system brings in a customer
record and another brings in the same customer, we don't really resolve these identities very
granularly unless there's an exact match on like email address. And even then we don't always do
it. We might have multiple records for the same person. So there's some complexities in how we
handle consumer data, how that data is related to the car dealership, which is ultimately our customer.
And we want to try to build a system that allows us to do
identity resolution at multiple different layers so that we can actually
ensure a golden record of sorts for a singular consumer and all the events that are related to
them can be sort of attached to this identity graph or context graph or whatever you want to call it.
So the idea of the CDP is to bring that all together and the end result should be
powering our existing applications. So our CDXB application, like our life cycle events,
and then powering some new experiences like voice and chat AI,
potential other sort of unique AI-driven recommendation engines, for example, on what
products or services this person might want to buy for their car. So it's not just voice and chat,
but there could be recommendation engines, there could be scoring engines, there could be lots of
different things we can build. But right now it's difficult because our records are not
unified and we don't have a consistent view of the consumer across all the different touch points.
I'll just add two things to that, if possible. One is why we can't buy something off the shelf
and the biggest challenge we have is we have multi-tenancy. So we can have 100 clients of ours
and you as a customer, so Mike as a customer, could be at three of our clients' locations,
right? And we as staffs don't need three Mike Paylors, we want one Mike Paylor that
belongs to three different properties, but then the attributes of Mike Paylor are specific to
a property. Example, if Mike Paylor comes to my dealership and gives me a phone number and then
goes to Alex's dealership and gives an email, as a CDP we should be able to see everything,
email and phone, but me as the client of dealership A, I should only be able to see the attributes
that Mike gave me, not the ones he gave the other dealership. So we need to be able to
see the attributes that Mike gave me, not the ones he gave the other dealership.
In other words, we can't cross pollinate. We can't use one dealer's data to benefit
another dealer. There's a conflict of interest, even if both dealers are our clients.
And we didn't want to have multiple of the same, because you could obviously do Mike Paylor,
this client, Mike Paylor, this client, whatever, but we just wanted to see the global views. So
that's why an off-the-shelf solution doesn't necessarily work for us, for what we're trying
to do. And really this first phase zero, so the scope of it is not the execution of, but more the
design and discovery phase to help us understand where our data is, how it's mapped, what identities
we could use in each of these objects that we're getting from, whether it's a CRM, DMS, Google,
Facebook, Twilio, whatever, what identities we could use to map this all back and then build
out this source of truth. So this phase one, the scope of it is more the discovery and understanding
phase, this phase zero rather. And then ideally this leads into phase one, two, or three of actually
development of the project. Yeah. And Mike did a damn good job of describing kind of our product
set, capabilities, our goal. I'd like to expand on it just a little bit. Our goal is to remove
the friction between a business, our client, and their customers, so their customers are more likely
to transact. So in terms of this whole project is to build a data layer, but the activation
of that data layer, to get more specific, then what Mike did is that you want to talk to the
customer, the consumer, in a way that resonates with them. If I like trucks, which I do, and Dan
likes sports cars, and Mike wants to drive a luxury vehicle, different terminology, different offers
are going to resonate with those individuals. So we need to have that contextualized
understanding of the customer and be able to activate it in a meaningful and dynamic way.
That's right. And I'll also, just to dive in a little bit about why the
scope is the way it is, Dan and Alex and I met yesterday to just chat about like
how to kick this off in the right way. And I think that what we want out of the next month is like a
very thorough dive into how do we build a new source of truth for this company to power
all products in the future. So for example, we have microservices and databases and the temptation
is always, well, let's just go grab the data from there. And we've already got a microservice for
that. We can use that, right? And I think thinking critically about like, is that a reliable
scaffolding to build upon? Or do we need to reinvent the data flow from start to finish? So for
example, a lot of the data comes from car dealership systems, like a dealer management system,
a DMS, or their CRM. We get inventory data that we scrape from their website about the cars and
their prices and things like that. So we need to think critically about like how the data flows
into DAS and how we want to actually join into that data flow and actually make the right
architecture so that we don't have to build on top of a poor scaffolding, a house of cards,
so to speak. So the temptation is always there to just say, hey, we've already got a service for
that. We know where the data is. That's not really what we want to achieve in the next month. We want
to achieve like an understanding of what do we build upon to make this work and what can we not
rely upon? Dan has some patterns and anti-patterns that maybe he can go through in the meetings to
come. We don't have to go through them all today, but just some examples of things that we feel
really good about that we can build upon, a queue of data events that we think is like really
reliable. And there's other systems that are complex SQL server, like SSIS jobs that we just
want to just toss out the window, that we want to go back to the drawing board, so to speak, on
those. So I think it's critical to think about like not how do we get the solution up and running
fastest, but how do we actually look at what we have and think this is lasting and we can build
with it. And this is a distraction and quite frankly, a weak link in the chain,
and we don't want to build upon that. Okay, it powers an existing experience today, but it's
pretty fragile and we need to just go back to the drawing board and get the data from the source
and transform it this way and put it into our CDP and then hook some services in so we can use
that instead. So I think for the next month, we want like a thorough dive on like
what do we actually have and what's reliable. And Dan can give you his input on here, he knows a lot
about what's reliable and what's known. And the other wrinkle in this is to keep in mind is that
Dan and Alex didn't build all these things themselves. Despite all the years that Alex
has been here, this company has grown through like six or seven different acquisitions.
Even from the start of the company, it was two different companies that merged that had
completely different technology stacks and they did totally different things. And so
a lot of what you'll find is deferred technical debt related to acquisitions that we've just sort
of dealt with. We've merged what we can, we've dealt, we've taken a stab at fixing glaring
issues, but there are still this notion of independent sources of record and maybe even
independent like technology stacks and databases and things like that. Some of it is to our
advantage, but some really isn't. And so you'll find a plethora of different tech stacks and
situations that you might be surprised for a company.
this small, how do we have so many different situations? Well, it's really because it was
a lot of acquisition in organic growth. Now, we have refactored a lot of things, and we can walk
you through that as well, but you might find that we've grown through acquisition, and therefore
we've grown in terms of complexity, which is not going to help us in this project. But, you know,
here we are, and I think it's just important for you guys to understand that concept as well. So,
yeah, I think that's a good enough overview for that one, but then I think that sets the stage
for some of the scope alignment, I guess, Leo. Right, sounds good. I think we can also skip
three, because we talked about those deliverables as part of the expectation in the overview,
but here they are written down. I'll share this agenda as well, and we've got it recorded,
I guess, technically. So, questions, we'll skip to those. In a second, just talk about some
logistics. The first one is, how do we get eyes on data sources, schemas, and existing architecture
docs is probably, you know, a couple of the quick ones that we can start on, so. Yeah, so.
Oh, sorry, Dan. Just, I just wanted to jump in here, and Leo, Dan's got a bunch of information,
and he can make available all of our repos and things like that, but I actually have a
sort of related question. We talked about this yesterday. Do you guys have any approach or
technology that would allow you to do this more thoroughly and faster than, like, a traditional
approach where we just hand you the documents and the code, and you guys introspect it? Is there
an LLM-based approach that allows you to, like, do more introspection and understanding very quickly?
Is there anything like that that you're thinking, hey, this would, like, really jumpstart this
initiative versus, like, Dan might have documentation for some of it, but not all,
and I've seen, like, projects like this get kind of stalled because Dan's the bottleneck and doesn't
have all the right documents right in front of him. So, just wanted to have a quick discussion
about how do you guys want to do your work, and then maybe Dan can chime in on what he
needs to provide access to. Well, so, a couple things. Like, there are some things that we can
definitely, and we will. So, we do a human and AI, like, you know, layer. So, before we start, we only
use models that we have, like, you know, business arrangements with. So, stuff that's hypersensitive,
we run through our, like, super secret AWS account and stuff. So, we're not using just, like,
you know, publicly retained data for, you know, whoever uses the models. Let's start with that
disclaimer. We've actually built some tools. So, I don't want this to turn into an ad, so I'll go
really quickly. That's called selling plastic clothes, right, Craig? Exactly. So, just making
sure he's still awake over there, since I can't see. You got me, man. We've got a couple tools
we've developed in-house. One is called Planopticon. It started as a quick way to make sure that we
could capture notes from meetings and action items, and it evolved into a whole bunch of other
stuff, specifically around knowledge extraction and project planning. You know, we use it actively
right now. Like, it's been in production for I don't know how many months, but we've got, like,
several projects that we run through this, and we use it for, like, you know, basically just a
data absorption layer. So, anything that the human doesn't get, like, you know, we usually capture
through this pretty well. It's got, like, thoroughness settings, multi-backend, you know,
experimental features. There's actually, like, four recorded meetings. If there are diagrams
on screen, it'll do, like, you know, image frame detection and then try to recreate the diagrams,
all that other stuff. Like, some of it is experimental, depending on the model that
you use and whatever. But that's one. For code, we've got Navigator or Navigador, depending if
you want to say it in Spanish. It's an AST and knowledge graph extractor from code. So, you
basically use it to discover stuff in repos. We also use it to, like, tether our agents so that
they can coordinate changes as stuff is happening live between storms. That's part of the software
factory series that I was talking about. Anyways, so, these are a couple of the tools that we use
to, like, do quick discovery. AST and, you know, basically knowledge graphs are super useful to
find the squirrely stuff in the code and gives us a good place to point agents and do discovery.
All those notes are put together, compiled, and human reviewed. Between that and a couple of
other agents we'll clean up to separate the really valuable stuff from the chaff and provide a
package of documentation. We like to do this because, you know, people forget. So, you know,
we're very documentation positive, I guess. That's a way to put it. Does that cover your
questions? I think so, yeah. I mean, I think I'll have to see the output for myself just
to understand. But I think it does. I think it tells me that maybe it gives Dan some hints on
what would be most useful for you guys to have access to right away versus, like, what's old
documentation you don't even want to refer to. The code is the documentation in a lot of ways,
but maybe Dan can talk a little bit about what's the best approach here. Yeah, I mean, we have
lots of data sources. Not everything is documented and some of the documentation we do have is old
and not necessarily trusted. I have kind of started to put together a couple things for you
guys just to understand what are these third-party integrations we have with everyone and trying to
understand what those models are. But, you know, for transparency, I'm also using AI to help me
build some of this stuff out, so it makes it a little easier. I can definitely get you the right
contacts for data and each kind of team. Each team has a lead, so I can get you in touch with that
person and they can kind of help funnel that stuff out. We have a data engineer that'll be able to
help you out, DevOps to get you into everything, so that shouldn't be a problem. For channels,
we use Microsoft Teams for most things. Obviously, you can email us, but Teams and Microsoft Stack
generally, so we don't have Slack. For the check-in, we could probably do a weekly check-in.
Mike, I don't know if there's a specific day that works best for you in terms of weekly check-in
and time, but I know Alex and I can be a little bit more open to it. Yeah, I mean, I guess probably
Leo's team and your team just to get aligned on, like, time zones, and then I can sort of...
I'm sure we're going to be looking at morning to afternoon, you know, your time, Dan,
no later. But yeah, let's see. I mean, is weekly enough? I guess that was the... I guess
the big thing here is weekly sort of screams there's a lot of work to do
independent of a meeting, which I think is great. It's just four weeks is kind of tight,
so if we go a week or two and then we have a meeting, we may not... I don't know how we want
to share progress and questions and answer over Teams, or if there's some other way to do it
where the meeting is really just about alignment on the next week versus, like, recapping what was
done because we're already aware of what was done. Cool. Yes, so I like to have a baseline
of cadence just to make sure that we have, like, a dedicated time to, you know, resolve blockers or
anything. The idea, of course, is we would be communicating way more frequently than once a week.
We've got a stack everywhere, so I'll just turn on Teams for this group so we can have, like,
a shared channel and have a, you know, one or several kind of channels so we can all just kind
of, you know, communicate synchronously. And then we can follow up on, you know, via email for stuff
that usually happens after hour. You'll find this group to be lively and working at odd hours,
usually all over the day. So with that, you know, just it's good. We'll match your stack
to provide some, you know, some quick channels and communications. And then I'll also provide,
like, a list of everybody's email and myself included so that we've got, like, a roster of,
you know, who to reach out to and whatever should their meeting, right?
While we're on working, I just have to chime in for a second. And I'm actually traveling
next week. I'll be in closer to your neck of the woods. I'll be in Salt Lake for the week
doing some meetings and just some stuff that I had scheduled. Maybe for next week we can
see if we can try working through initial code for documentation and access and use it kind of as a
ramp up week so that we can start exchanging and do some, you know, read ahead before we schedule
kind of deep sessions. And then hopefully by then also we come prepared and we have read some of the
materials and come in with, like, a better sense of stuff. And then, of course, we'll have a check-in
and, you know, time to be discussed. But I'll be a little bit less available for meetings next week
because I, like, you know, booked this stuff a couple weeks ago, so. Yep, understood.
All right. Real quick, that's the contacts there. Just being on Alex and I will be your main point
of contacts. We will divvy you out to, depending on, like, what you need. If you need data guy,
I'll get data guy. You know, certain app guy, I'll get app guy. But, you know, Alex and I,
and we'll be able to get you whoever you need. Between the two of us, we'll be able to get taken
care of. I'll probably be your main point, but Alex is there as well. If I'm ever in a meeting or
sick for the day or whatever, he'll be there for you as well. Yeah, I mean, it's basically, like,
if the dialogue or question is more technical in nature, Dan's probably your guy. And if it's more
product focused or philosophical in nature, I'm your guy. Yeah.
Perfect. And usually, for anything, I'll be your guy.
Unless it's something serious and then it's Craig and you talk to him and beat him up.
So, cool. So, what we're doing this week, it's kind of the end of the day, Wednesday,
but we're basically doing some initial research on best practices for CDP,
what is the latest structural stuff, architecture, and reading through the initial proposals.
This is just very light so that everybody can come in situated.
Other than that, we'll start putting together a list of these are good things to look for,
which we'll go after, that's next page, and then we can figure out access.
And I'll get everything set up as well so that we can communicate and collaborate effectively
over the next month, essentially.
No hard balkers, I think, so let's move on.
So, these are just some notes that I've put together from our conversations
and are meant as conversation starters.
If something doesn't make sense to recover, we can skip.
But the first one is data sources, actually.
So, we mentioned that there's probably about over 100 data sources,
and then how many of those are super clear, how many we know they exist,
but we don't have full control, or maybe it's a legacy app in life support,
and then calibrate of how much do you want to spend cataloging versus validating.
Yeah, so, Dan, do you want to try to, do you want to start, like,
maybe backwards on what the 100 data sources is and what VSS is?
Yeah, so, yeah, 100 data sources, maybe by exaggeration,
so we have integrations with a lot of different places, right, CRMs, DMSs,
social platforms, like everything from Facebook, Meta, Instagram, Reddit,
Craigslist, like all these different things.
We have integrations into tools that we use, like SendGrid, MailChimp,
or, you know, Twilio, and all these other places.
We have lots of different data sources that we're connected to,
so we need to understand, A, what are they, and do we need to map them?
Because some of them we may not, right?
Some of them may not be useful to us in a CDP.
That being said, our CDP, I like to call it, personally, more of a CDV,
because V is vehicles, and we're also getting vehicle data
and mapping what's going on with that vehicle at the same time.
But, anyway, we've got a lot of different data points to map.
I can help you find a lot of those.
Our engineering team and data team will help you
to map a lot of those out as well.
VSS stands for Vehicle Smart Scores,
which is kind of a tool we're putting together
that is not for our client, per se, but for the consumer.
Our client would purchase it, but it goes to the consumer,
and it's almost like a scorecard-type tool.
Right now, if you want to know what your car is worth,
you go to Kelley Blue Book, you put in your information,
and it says it's worth about $2,500 or $25,000, whatever it is, right?
High level, this is a tool to monitor that over time.
You get an email.
It kind of tells you what you think your score is of the vehicle
based off the maintenance you've been doing on it,
based off the recalls on that vehicle,
based off the maintenance you've been doing,
the condition and what it's worth and all this other stuff.
It kind of gives you a score to an idea
of what that vehicle may be worth if you do anything with it.
We're using it as well as for that.
It's also like a sales tool for the dealership
where they can advertise upselling or particular add-ons and products
or get them to buy a new car.
At a high level, quickly, that's kind of what VSS is.
We're going to have a bunch of data points that we need to map through,
but the idea is the end of us building this CDP,
we're going to have ingestion of data, the identity graph,
and at least enough data in there to power this VSS app.
Obviously, we have a lot more data points, and it'll expand over time,
but that was kind of what the MVP spec was for.
And it was very consumer and vehicle-oriented
because of the product we were trying to build.
So we don't have to pay an overly large amount of attention to VSS or anything.
It's not any more important necessarily than any of the other data points that we have.
It just happens to be consumer-oriented,
so the notion of the CDP having vehicle information, vehicle history,
personal information, that's all super important to the consumer and to the dealer.
There's lots of other data that's not in there,
and that's also going to be hugely important to the CDP.
It's important to mention that just like we were talking about earlier with the cross-pollination,
if we are accommodating unique consumers, unique vehicles within our data set, here's a scenario.
So you own a vehicle, and you get it serviced at a particular dealership.
You then take that vehicle to a different dealership, and you trade it in.
They then take ownership of that vehicle, and they sell it as a pre-owned vehicle.
We can't use the service history from dealer A for dealer B,
who now owns that vehicle and then sells it to a different customer,
who then brings it back to dealer B and services it.
It's all about the source of the data.
If we're getting it from a third party, it's probably free game,
but anything a dealer gives us, we cannot then give to another dealer.
Does that make sense?
I'm not trying to introduce unnecessary complexity, but I felt that was an important point to mention.
This is great.
Would it be safe to say, then, we want to track both the people and vehicles
as individual kind of core entities for the CDP, right?
I mean, honestly, I saw it that way.
Mike had a slightly different view of that connection.
We want your opinion.
Look through the data.
You can come to us and be like, this is why I think this approach is better,
because I think we internally had some discussions.
I had one thought.
Mike had a different.
Alex, maybe different balance between both.
I don't know.
You come to us as the experts of this data management, and you can say,
this is the best approach, and here's why.
What I will say, again, it's hard for me to separate the activation of the data
from the data layer itself, but, like, yes, those are separate entities, right,
but together they're also a unique entity, right?
The important thing to us is, as it pertains to a vehicle
and the relationship with a consumer, is that they own that vehicle,
and then they take certain actions that pertain to that vehicle, right?
So there's, like, a vehicle and a customer,
and then there's the customer-vehicle combination that's kind of the most important
output there, right?
And that customer-vehicle combination has to be tied to a single business.
Maybe that clarifies it a little bit.
Yeah, and, like, I think we have to look at the CDP through two different lenses.
This is another aspect that we need to sort of drive home is that there's going
to be certain data about a consumer that's DAS technology-owned and understood,
and there are certain pieces of data that are dealer-customer-specific data points.
And when I think about the vehicle, I think, from the dealer's perspective,
if we're their CDP provider, they care about the vehicle that Leo just bought
and bought from them three years ago.
They care a lot about that's really their relationship to the consumer is the vehicle
and the services around the vehicle that they're purchasing.
So, you know, but internally at DAS, we might care.
We might personally have less to gain from vehicle specifics, you know,
but that's sort of short-sighted in the sense that, you know,
there's two different sort of layers of looking at this.
You know, there's going to be data that's really critical for all of DAS to understand
about the consumer, and then there's going to be data that's more critical
for the dealer relationship, like Alex said.
So, yeah, there's sort of layers that we need to keep in mind as we think about it.
And maintaining that integrity around, like, the data boundaries is also super important.
In terms of, like, the questions above, I don't know if we answered that question earlier, Leo,
about is there anything pressuring us.
I think the answer is no.
Obviously, there's pressure and time and, you know, there's a lot that Alex
and Dan are going through to deliver the most value as soon as possible for the company,
but in general, there isn't any launch pending on this right away.
Anything that's sort of high-pressure, we need to launch, we're going to try to take steps to build it
in ways that would be subpar but acceptable at first while we wait on this thing to be fully built out.
Having said that, we want to do it as quickly as possible.
Makes sense.
Shall we move over to data identity?
Sure.
So, what's the first one?
How does pulling data models from existing systems with internal tooling work?
Can you walk us through what you have?
Format coverage, how current it is, and how do we get access?
Dan, do you want to?
Well, I mean, again, this is a pretty loaded question, to be honest, and as you dig in,
you'll see that our data models are different to all the different systems due to acquisitions.
There's different language sets, different models, different integrations.
Sometimes we're integrating with the same company in two different systems in two different ways
with two different API keys, and it can be kind of difficult.
As we dig in, it'll probably be easier to show you and walk through this stuff.
I can also provide you some documentation I'm putting together.
together on some of the formats and stuff. Most of our stuff is API connections, but there is some
old-school ways of like ADF, which is basically an XML, or we're doing FTPs of CSV files from
third parties. But the majority of what we're doing is API connections with proper JSON models.
So that bit will be pretty straightforward. And again, as we look through this, some I'm
confident enough you can, hey, I'm going to hook with this brand new system that Dask built that
ingests this already and just pull from that side. That makes it a lot easier than I'm going
to integrate individually to each one. That one's a bit more difficult because then everyone's
slightly different. How do we identify customers across our system today? Well, we don't. They're
not across systems. Each system can have the same person in it with different IDs, and there's no
real integration across them at all. So Alex English can be in our chat system and our lead
response system and our CDXP system, and he's a completely different Alex English across the
board. There's no joining that data. That's how it is today. That's how it is today.
Where do we expect identity to break down the most?
Families. Yeah. Most things we have have IDs. We generally have a name and an email address and
stuff like that. We have some basic identifiers that you should be able to do deterministic
patches on and make it a bit more trouble when we're like doing stuff with Facebook and we get
someone clicked on a Facebook thing and we get a Facebook ID because we have no idea what that
Facebook ID is belonging to in the Facebook world or the Google world or those kinds of things maybe
challenging. Let me take a stab here. Go ahead. I think that one example of where it can get really
messy. You're a consumer. You want to buy a car. You submit a lead to a dealership. You use a
throwaway email and maybe you use the name Mike Paylor and you submit it for a particular vehicle.
You then take a test drive, come in, negotiate, yada, yada, yada, and you drive off the lot in
a different vehicle, right? Most dealerships aren't going to A, update the vehicle, so we can't use
that closed lead as a record of a sale. Secondarily, but it is like an interest indicator, right?
Secondarily, when you purchase, you may use your real email, right? Use a hotmail as a throwaway
email to submit a lead, but when you actually transact, you provide your Gmail and maybe you
use your legal business name or whatever your legal name of Michael Paylor instead of Mike.
And so there's like when we talk about identity resolution, that's one area where it can get kind
of messy, right? It's up to the consumer to self-select and submit their information
through these different systems and then they provide it to the dealer and the dealer enters
it into their DMS, which is like a record of their transactions, and then we get both, right? And we
have to kind of reconcile that. Now, in the past, we've chosen that the DMS is the source of truth
because there's dollars attached to it. It's a record of a sale, but all that information about
Mike Paylor is valuable to us in one way or another. That make sense? That's a good point.
And that and the nonsense data people add into forms all the time.
How do you reconcile that like, okay, you've got Mike Paylor and Michael Paylor in two different
emails and he owns this vehicle, right? But then he goes to chat on the website and it's Mike Paylor
and like how do you, like you have to find some kind of identifying mechanism to be able to stitch
that chat record back to his customer record on our side and the LLM chat then has to be able to
say, okay, well, I see that you own this vehicle and you also like these and now I'm conversing
with you with an understanding, a basic understanding of who you are and what you like.
And it's not just like, you know, trying to find information that it skips the discovery part of
that conversation. So that's the end goal, but it can be messy because you're left to consumers
who historically behave unpredictably. Yeah. Some of our apps do have reliable IDs and we'll
be able to go through those. Some are going to be easier than others, but there are going to be
some messy ones along the way. In terms of number eight, I don't believe any data sources will be
off limits for any reason. Mike, would you agree with that? Is there anything you think that we
wouldn't want them to access? No. I mean, there are things that I'm not sure. There's some sort
of tangents at the business level that I don't think are as important, but might as well access
at all. I don't. Yeah. Go ahead, Leo. This is a subdivision of that and a little bit of the next
one, but that also includes like for identity resolution, you can also use like location based
on like IP addressing and IP masking. So, but also like location-based and IP-based information is
technically like PII as well. So some jurisdictions are tricky about storing that and like all that
stuff, but does that make sense? Yeah, we're okay with, we already have PII all over the place. We're
okay with storing it. We definitely want to have an easier way to follow CCPA and GPLPR, whatever,
where if someone says delete my information, it'll be a lot easier to do it if it's in one place
versus us having to go to 20 databases to try and clear someone out, right? So as long as we're able
to do deletion requests and redaction requests when needed, and ideally if it's encrypted at
rest and encrypted in transit, I don't see a problem in holding PII. And we're not holding to
any, we're not SOC 2 and not, you know, any kind of, I think one of our apps is technically HIPAA
technically, but I don't know if we really need to worry too much about that. We can carve that out
separately. I would say that it would be nice to have modern techniques around data masking that
make sense here. If there is any sensitive data, if there are tried and true strategies to improve
the security, let's look at implementation of those from the start in case we need to do a SOC
2 or something later and want to attest to how we handle the data. But yeah.
But we're also only operating really in North America, right, Dan or Alex? Like US and Canada?
Yeah, North America. We've tried to break into Canada and have limited success. So, but yeah,
that we do have a small Canadian presence. One last philosophical point that I'll add,
right, as we've spent a lot of time on this call talking about dealerships,
automotive industry, that's our core vertical, but long-term, we want this system to support
expansion to other verticals. So, I don't want that to be lost. We need the flexibility in the
framework to be able to support primarily automotive and then automotive adjacent and then,
you know, you name it. Yeah, we also do things with, you know, bedding and generators and stuff
like that. So, when we're building out a CDP and we say the vehicle relationship, there is a vehicle
relationship with our dealers, but maybe we want to, when we're doing the data modeling,
think about it as just a piece of inventory that this person owns, because an inventory could be
a vehicle or could be a generator or could be a t-shirt or whatever, right? Mattress. So, it may be,
you just think about that as we're building out the architecture and the database schema design.
So, do we want these to be separate or would it work cross verticals if we sell it to someone that
sells, I don't know, quad bikes all of a sudden, or RVs or trailers or something, you know,
because that would be fine. So, appliances, yeah. Anything more than identifying. Right.
Got it. Go ahead. Anything else on the privacy and compliance? No, I think. So, in number 10,
we get the data. I mean, technically, we own it, but we can't share dealers' data across to other
dealers. There's nothing, I think, in writing that says that. I could call me wrong, but it's more
about, I don't know, relationships, and it would definitely be a bad thing if we started giving
away that data. Yeah. I mean, our point of view is that we're using the data, but as the dealer,
you own your own data. If you ask me for the data, I will give it to you.
I'm not going to use it to benefit your competitor. Got it. I'm not going to sell it to anybody.
Right. It would create this conflict of interest if we're giving away information from one dealer
to another. We want to gain all 18,000 dealerships in the US, and that only happens if we're being
safe about their data between each other. Right. There's no interest in data brokerage
later down the line for identity resolution. Well, that could be, but it can't be dealership
data that they provided to us. If we're getting it from a third party or aggregating it ourselves,
because we integrate with third parties, like one is called Recall Masters. It gives us recall data.
We can use that wherever we want. That's not a dealer-provided data. But if a dealer says,
Mike Paylor just came in and made this payment, we then can't share that with other dealers. So,
we've really got to classify it as it comes in, where that source of data is, and then
where that source came from, so then we can filter out those sources later on how we want to
share that data. Cool. I think this is actually a good place to stop, because the rest of the
questions are not going to be five minutes. Okay. But I think, let me just scroll through. This is
infrastructure, and yeah, I don't think this is a now conversation anyways. Okay. So,
we'll get stuff started. Thank you so much for meeting with us today. If we can get a copy of
the recording, because it helps for our notes and processing and planopticon and all that stuff that
I was mentioning, that'll be great. At the same time, I guess I'll be in touch to schedule some
work sessions over the next immediate short-term future, I reckon, and follow up with
a summary of notes and action items collected from today's call, just as a reminder, and I'll
also share the agenda for everybody, and then we can probably async and go over Teams chat and
everything else for the rest of the bits. Yeah. You let us know when you want to meet again.
We'll happily make that happen. You let us know if you have questions.